der bundestag schafft eine eindeutige
rechtsgrundlage für die korona maßnahmen
draußen protestieren tausende dagegen es
gibt ausschreitungen
raus aus afghanistan weil sie den tramp
sieht die hälfte der us-truppen ab die
taliban begrüßen dass die verbündeten
warnen was nun herr löw nach dem spanien
debakel nimmt die debatte und trainer
und mannschaft fahrt auf
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen an
einem ereignisreichen nachrichten
mittwoch und das betrifft auch den sport
mit norbert könig ja heute gibt es nur
ein thema ist gestern abend im
schnellverfahren haben bundestag und
bundesrat heute das
infektionsschutzgesetz reformiert um im
kampf gegen korona auch rechtlich besser
gewappnet zu sein
doch während die mehrheit der
abgeordneten und der länder für das neue
sogenannte bevölkerungsschutz gesetz
stimmte wurde draußen lautstark dagegen
demonstriert am brandenburger tor ging
die polizei mit wasserwerfern und
pfefferspray gegen demonstranten vor
einige hatten unter anderem steine
flaschen und böller geworfen es gab
verletzte und dutzende festnahmen
bevor wir auf die geschehnisse des tages
auch im bundestag schauen erklärt uns
thomas konsum worüber heute abgestimmt
wurde
das infektionsschutzgesetz es regelt wie
ansteckende krankheiten zu verhindern
und zu bekämpfen sind problem das gesetz
hat die aktuelle pandemie nicht
vorhergesehen es ist daher nicht
vollständig jetzt wichtige details
fehlen etwa die masken und abstands
pflicht die fließen nun ins gesetz ein
damit soll es mehr rechtssicherheit
geben für die korona maßnahmen die
hatten bisher länderchefs und kanzlerin
abgesteckt teils so gerichte ohne klare
rechtsgrundlage außerdem angestrebt mehr
transparenz alle corona maßnahmen müssen
begründet werden und befristet sein auf
vier wochen verlängerung möglich ganz
praktisch geregelt sind etwa
verdienstausfälle von eltern und
gottesdienste und demos bleiben
geschützt verbot nur wenn sonst nichts
hilft beim schutz vor infektionen
bekämpft werden
die anpassen das ist heute geschehen
bundestag und bundesrat haben das gesetz
zum infektionsschutz präzisiert und
verabschiedet daniel ponce bei der
abstimmung im bundestag erhielt das
gesetz wie erwartet eine mehrheit nach
teils hitzige debatte und vor debatte zu
beginn will die afg eine vertagung
erzwingen alle übrigen fraktionen
kritisieren den versuch stimmen dagegen
so beginnt mit verzögerungen die
eigentliche debatte über den
gesetzentwurf die spd rechtfertigt ihnen
hatten bisher eine allgemeine
generalklausel auf der viele
verordnungen umgesetzt wurden und dass
wir diese jetzt präzisieren mit diesem
gesetzentwurf ist doch genau der punkt
dass wir eben einschränken dass wir
sagen wir bestritten wir müssen
begründen das infektionsschutzgesetz der
bundesregierung ist die größte
grundrechts einschränkung in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik dass die
regierung die vom volk geräten
abgeordneten vor vollendete tatsachen
stellt widerspricht dem geist der
demokratie und dem grundgesetz die
körperliche unversehrtheit steht
übrigens auch in dem grundgesetz dass
sie gerade hoch gehalten haben ist ihnen
das leid davon hat mich gar nichts
gehört ja genau dann ist ihnen das leid
auf den intensivstationen in den
krankenhäusern in den familien
diejenigen die langzeitschäden haben ist
ihnen dieses leid egal
für das gesetz stimmten mit union und
spd die grünen dagegen neben der afd die
linke und die fdp vor allem wegen § 28a
er ist im kern einer aufzählung von
freiheits einschränkungen diese
grundrechtseingriffe müssten nach dem
prinzip wenn dann klar einer konkret
definierten situation zugeordnet werden
jeder eingriff in die grund und
freiheitsrechte die so bitter erkämpft
worden sind die so unser fundament ist
dass uns hier streiten können bedarf der
debatte und zustimmung oder ablehnung
des bundestages und genau das ist nicht
vorgesehen
deswegen kann man dem nicht zustimmen
wie die spd-abgeordnete mast twitterte
versuchten unterdessen in den bundestag
eingeschlossene personen in büros
einzelne abgeordnete einzudringen
eine mehrheit erhielt das gesetz am ende
trotz allem kurz darauf auch im
bundesrat
wiederum wenig später unterzeichnete ist
der bundespräsident so dass es morgen in
kraft treten kann
ja da war sie wieder die kritik das
parlament werde auch im neuen gesetz
nicht eingebunden und anna banerjee wie
steht es damit ist der vorwurf
berechtigt diese kritik kommt
tatsächlich von mehreren seiten von den
linken haben wir gerade im beitrag
gehört
grüne und fdp fordern schon länger einen
sogenannten parlamentsvorbehalt das
würde bedeuten bei grundrechtseingriffen
müsste das parlament zustimmen und auch
die spd soll sich dafür eingesetzt haben
aber sich eben nicht durchgesetzt haben
jetzt bei der vorbereitung dieser
gesetzesänderung und so hat das
parlament heute erstmal eine schieflage
korrigiert und hat den rahmen gesetzt
für künftige corona maßnahmen und
grundrechts einschränkungen der
opposition geht das nicht weit genug und
verfassungsrechtler werden sich auch
noch mal über den den text beugen und
schauen ist das ganze jetzt
verfassungsgemäß aber bundestag
bundesrat und bundesrat am heute
mehrheitlich gesagt das ist jetzt nötig
diesen schritt zu machen um die
kommenden maßnahmen die er jetzt im
winter auch von mir zu erwarten sind auf
eine zuverlässige rechtliche basis zu
stellen
die diskussion über das mitspracherecht
des parlamentes ist damit aber noch
nicht beendet
die erklärung von sharon terlep energy
in berlin vielen dank dafür
während also im reichstag debattiert
wird wurde draußen demonstriert mehrere
tausend menschen protestierten am
brandenburger tor gegen die korona
maßnahmen ignorierten aber zu meisten
masken pflicht und abstandsregel die
polizei versuchte die demonstration
aufzulösen die situation aufgeheizt
sylvia bleßmann über die proteste in
berlin
wasserwerfer vor dem reichstag
gegendemonstranten kein harter strahl
aber ungemütlich sollte es werden für
all jene je nach wiederholter
aufforderung nicht weichen wollten als
die polizei die veranstaltung beendete
weil gegen hygiene auflagen verstoßen
wurde
unverständnis bei den teilnehmern
menschen die einfach nur für ihr recht
einstehen für frieden freiheit und
demokratie
das auto das eigene volk mit
wasserwerfern vorgegangen ist das ist
doch unglaublich das hätte ich heute
fühlen und nicht für möglich gehalten
tausende waren auf der demo wollten
gegen die staatlichen regeln zur
eindämmung der korona pandemie
demonstrieren
als die polizei die versammlung auflösen
wurden ansagen überstunden ignoriert es
war schnell offenbar dass die personen
in den platz nicht verlassen werden den
aufforderungen der polizei berlin keine
folge leisten sodass entschieden wurde
die wasserwerfer zu positionieren und
einzusetzen
in form einer begegnung der menschen der
insel hatte den einsatz von
wasserwerfern gern verhindert die
polizei sprach am nachmittag von 120
festnahmen und vielen gewaltsamen
auseinandersetzungen
das war es deutliche ziel dieser
demonstrationsteilnehmer die regeln zu
brechen möglichst zum reichstag
durchzubrechen und dass die polizei dann
nach so vielen ansagen die regeln
durchsetzt das war klar vereinbart und
ich denke das muss dann auch deutlich
gemacht werden dass der staat sich das
nicht gefallen lässt
wer regeln bewusst bricht muss mit
harten mitteln des rechtsstaats rechnen
sogar erst nach stunden beruhigte sich
die lage in berlin
und wir schauen auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen da gehen die neuinfektionen den
dritten tag in folge im vergleich zur
vorwoche zurück das robert koch institut
meldet heute 17 1561 neue fälle binnen
24 stunden
am vergangenen mittwoch lag die zahl bei
rund 18.500
der anteil positiver tests ist dagegen
angestiegen und zwar auf aktuell mehr
als neun prozent ein höchstwert der
bislang nur anfang april einmal
verzeichnet wurde
warum die etwas niedrigeren
infektionszahlen nicht gleich eine
trendwende bedeuten dass können sie
ausführlich im faktencheck in der zdf-
heute- app nachlesen
dort halten wir sie auch über alle
anderen entwicklungen in sachen corona
auf dem laufenden
interessante neuigkeiten gibt es beim
thema impfstoff und zwar vom mainzer
unternehmen bei montech und seinem
amerikanischen partner phase der
gemeinsam entwickelte impfstoff ist nach
eigenen angaben sogar zu 95 prozent
wirksam
bisher waren sie von mehr als 90 prozent
ausgegangen
es gebe bei dem mittel keine
sicherheitsbedenken teilten die
unternehmen mit
noch in diesem jahr wollen sie 50
millionen impfdosen herstellen
im nächsten jahr bis zu 1,3 milliarden
und noch ein blick nach russland mit
dramatischen zahlen
während in westeuropa viele von einer
zweiten welle sprechen ist dort die
erste noch gar nicht abgeebbt die
maßnahmen scheinen kaum zu greifen bin
eines tages sind jetzt 456 menschen mit
oder an dem chor ohne virus gestorben so
viele wie nie zuvor
insgesamt sind es mehr als 34.000
todesopfer christian senn berichtet es
gibt keine freien betten kranke sitzen
auf stühlen erzählt eine unbekannte
frauenstimme ein handy video aufgenommen
offenbar von einer patientin in einer
krankenstation in toms in den letzten
wochen häufen sich berichte und videos
über unzumutbare zustände in vielen
russischen regionen
es fehlt an allem betten personal
schutzausrüstung auch hier in der stadt
kaum wird ein bett frei und jemand
entlassen rasen schon die krankenwagen
dorthin und schon ist es wieder belegt
man muss echt glück haben um den
richtigen moment zu erwischen
moskau bleibt russlands corona hotspot
die bettenkapazitäten in der hauptstadt
wurden erhöht
provisorische krankenhäuser errichtet
wie hier in dieser eissporthalle
ältere menschen sollen das haus nicht
verlassen die unis bleiben zu bars und
restaurants hingegen sind geöffnet
müssen aber um 23 uhr schließen
die hoffnungen liegen auf dem russischen
corona impfstoff sputnik wie der nach
offiziellen angaben eine wirksamkeit von
92 prozent haben soll
derzeit laufen massentests kritik am
zulassungsverfahren kommt nicht nur aus
dem ausland sondern auch von russischen
wissenschaftlern
ich vertraue dem in russland
entwickelten impfstoff ehrlich gesagt
nicht so sehr
denn die regulierungsbehörden in
russland sind rückständig vor allem in
den usa und europa sind medizinische
präparate viel strenger reguliert warten
auf den impfstoff und das ohne einen
neuen streng lockdown wie im frühjahr
die angeschlagene wirtschaft will man
trotz der pandemie nicht weiter
schwächen und den traum nicht aufgeben
von unbeschwerten zeiten alle appelle
und warnungen waren umsonst us-präsident
trump hat den abzug weiterer truppen aus
afghanistan angeordnet ohne sich mit den
nato partnern abzusprechen
und die sind alarmiert das was wir
bisher erreicht haben dürfen nicht durch
überstürzte handlungen gefährdet werden
warnt außenminister mars bis mitte
januar soll die zahl der us soldaten auf
etwa 2.500 reduziert werden
aus washington eines traums
wahrscheinlich ist er nur deswegen
berufen worden der neue
verteidigungsminister loyal ist er zu
präsident trump er verkündet die
erfüllung eines wahlversprechens von
trump eine truppenreduzierung in
afghanistan und irak
vor dem hintergrund der opfer von
tausenden amerikanischen soldaten und
unseres enormen fortschritts über zwei
jahrzehnte bringen wir nun die konflikte
zu einem erfolgreichen und
verantwortungsbewussten abschluss unter
der mutigen führung von präsident frank
sein vorgänger hatte einen truppenabzug
kritisch gesehen und wurde von trump
geschasst bis mitte januar soll nun die
truppenstärke im irak und in afghanistan
auf jeweils 2500 verringert werden
auf widerstand stößt das auch bei trump
getreuen
sie warnen vor einem abzug den die
sicherheitslage nicht rechtfertige wenn
ein überstürzter abzug aus afghanistan
oder irak wäre meiner meinung nach ein
fehler
trump zieht den truppenabzug durch aus
rein politischen motiven damit gefährdet
er den friedensprozess in afghanistan
und setzt die dort verbleibenden
soldaten einem großen risiko aus die
eigenen soldaten und die der verbündeten
per tweet feuer trump derweil den chef
der wahl sicherheitsbehörde
der hatte in einem bericht trumps
behauptung von wahlbetrug zurückgewiesen
die wahl vom dritten november sei die
sicherste in der geschichte gewesen
das widerspricht dem was der präsident
sagt deswegen wurde heraus geworfen da
läuft gerade eine loyalität
säuberungsaktion im weißen haus
verschanzt sich im weißen haus der
anstehende urlaub in florida abgesagt es
scheint als wolle er sich ganz darauf
konzentrieren
seinem nachfolger joe biden den staat zu
erschweren
die 737 max von boeing seit gut
anderthalb jahren darf keine dieser
maschinen starten sicherheitshalber
jetzt gab die us flugaufsicht so etwas
wie grünes licht allerdings unter
auflagen
zuerst muss eine neue steuerungs
software installiert werden
dazu kommen wartungsarbeiten und piloten
trainings es dürfte also noch etwas
dauern
der passagierflieger war im märz 2009 10
aus dem verkehr gezogen worden
zuvor waren zwei maschinen abgestürzt
dabei kamen 300 4 346 menschen ums leben
die hurrikan-saison in mittelamerika ist
ungewöhnlich verheerend und ungewöhnlich
lang gerade fegte der dreißigste
wirbelsturm in diesem jahr über die
region utah traf mit etwa 250 km
pro stunde in nicaragua mindestens sechs
menschen starben dort mehr als 60.000
mussten in sicherheit gebracht werden
auch in honduras und el salvador soll es
nach noch unbestätigten berichten tote
gegeben haben
ja und im sport gibt es heute natürlich
nur ein thema wie geht es weiter für die
nationalmannschaft der gestrigen pleite
in silvia damals ja also ich glaube da
gibt es erst mal nur einen wirklich
riesen fragezeichen
die mannschaft harmlos der trainer
ratlos das 0 6 gegen spanien ist die
höchste niederlage einer deutschen
nationalmannschaft im zeitalter des
fernseh fußballs joachim löw ist schwer
unter druck
seine dunkle garderobe war dem anlass
angemessen und passte zum auftritt
leblos blutleer passiv so präsentierten
sie sich bis auf neuer genügte keiner
höheren ansprüchen kein kampf kein
aufbäumen keine körpersprache insgesamt
eine sportliche null leistung in
jeglicher beziehung war alles schlecht
den rabenschwarzen tag und deswegen sind
wir alle natürlich auch um riesig
enttäuscht und absolut sauer nach der
höchsten pleite in der ära löw werden
wieder forderungen lauter man möge doch
boateng hummels müller zurückholen doch
die personalpolitik ist nur einen
kritikpunkt von vielen der bundestrainer
gerät zunehmend unter druck ob ich mich
jetzt ob ich mir sorgen machen muss um
meinen job müssen andere fragen also von
daher kann ich jetzt so spontan hier
nicht beantworten
direktor bierhoff präsident keller
halten löw fest wollen mit ihm den
eingeschlagenen weg weitergehen denn das
vertrauen meint bierhoff ist vollkommen
da absolut daran ändert auch dieses
spiel nichts die diskussionen rund um
dieses debakel und um die zukunft des
bundestrainers werden den dfb ins em
jahr begleiten
markus hahn steht an der dfb zentrale in
frankfurt am main die verantwortlichen
bekräftigen nach einem kurzen treffen in
münchen dass joachim löw bundestrainer
bleiben soll wo liegt das hauptproblem
nach dieser historischen blamage ja erst
einmal joachim löw bleibt bunt
trainer der verband halte am nachmittag
schriftlich mit sie werden den
eingeschlagenen weg weitergehen heißt
kein rausschmiss kein rücktritt fakt
dabei ist der deutsche fussball steckt
in einer veritablen krise
und man stellt sich die fragen sind
diese probleme nicht auch hausgemacht
hat der dfb nicht das kerngeschäft
fußball schon längst aus den augen
verloren
denn präsidenten kommen und gehen und
viele und verband kümmern sich eher um
die eigenen interessen und gehalte als
um den sport bestes beispiel ex boss
grindel hat den vertrag mit joachim löw
schon vor der wm in russland bis zum
jahr 2022 verlängert und die nationalelf
mit löw und bierhoff ist ein eigener
mikrokosmos völlig eigenständig es fehlt
ein korrektiv jemand mit fachwissen der
auch mal kritisch nachfragt und so ist
es eben so wie es gerade gehört wurde
ein weiter-so eigene analysen und keine
frischen impulse von außen und genau das
denke ich merkte man dem team und dem
spiel an
max raabe vielen dank für die
einschätzungen nach frankfurt am main
und das war es von uns ja und wir haben
noch die zahlen vom mittwoch lotto
die gewinnzahlen lauten 819 29 35 41 49
und die superzahl 7 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf flotte punkt zdf.de und
im zdf text auf seite 55 7 bisher war
der november zu trocken aber von
nordwesten her naht nun regen die
details hat gleich ist in terry beim
wetter so viel von uns danke für ihr
interesse
das heute journal mit claus kleber um
viertel vor zehn und uns gibt's morgen
wieder punkt 7 einen gemütlichen abend
wünschen wir
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter neuerung kommt von
nordwesten aufgezogen und dieses
regenband ihr das überquert uns morgen
tagesverlauf südostwärts das nächste
regenband steht schon zur stelle und
kommt hinterher schauen wir in die nacht
im nordwesten gibt es viele wolken und
es regnet ganz im süden klart es auf an
der donau bildet sich nebel dort
temperaturen bis minus 1 grad und im
westen sind es zehn grad morgen am
vormittag liegt das regengebiet aus der
nacht quer über deutschland von
nordwesten kommt dieses nächste
ringgebiet rein teilweise gibt es
stürmische böen um südwest zum
nachmittag wandert der ganze regen
weiter südostwärts dann ist das
sturmfeld im nordosten deutschlands bei
temperaturen bis sieben grad im südosten
deutschlands und 13 grad hier in den
östlichen landesteilen schauen wir auf
die nächsten tage
am freitag an den alpen noch schneefall
das lästern allmählich nach bei zwei bis
acht grad nach norden hin schauer ab
samstag wird es wieder milder und
hauptsächlich im norden viele wolken und
regen und windig bei vier bis zwölf grad
insgesamt damit ein schöner abend